what's going on guys this is Rob and I
know I'm a little bit late to this party
but I've been really really busy for the
last few days and so I figured I'd go
ahead and offer my thoughts you know
such as they are on spider-man's staying
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
really don't even know if anybody cares
anymore but but nonetheless you know I
think that that spider-man's staying in
the MCU actually saves it and I know it
seems to run sort of counter to to the
video that I made before where I was
talking about you know the Sony doesn't
he deal and and I still believe that
Disney was not unreasonable for
requesting what they requested but the
irony of this all is that in my in my my
red notebook this is my note-taking book
I actually outlined a plan to
essentially create a 10 year long epic
and in Sony that would involve like
venom and a lot of the villains things
like that that would basically create
this this kind of 10 year long epic
similar to what Marvel did for the first
10 years of the MCU that would culminate
in essentially an Avengers I'm sorry an
infinity war slash Avengers in-game kind
of story
that would fall rank-and-file and would
actually involve the character of Nova
symbiote god I don't think it's gonna
happen I've got to chart it out it's
really really cool I'm sure a lot of you
guys probably gonna be like tell us what
it is but but nonetheless so with with
spider-man staying in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it basically it
basically keeps it afloat and and here's
the reason why what do you look at the
MCU for the last 10 years what would you
sit like about walk up to you and I said
what would you say the overarching theme
of the last 10 years of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe was I think most
people would say it was the rise and
fall of Tony Stark and indeed it was you
know I mean it's not really to tear down
the movies that were made you know with
Captain America and Thor and and The
Incredible Hulk whatever Norton you know
as I enjoy that actually I really liked
it but it's not really designed to tear
down any of the other actors who were
part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
mean really it's successful because of
everything they contributed but I really
do feel like it was the rise and fall of
Tony Stark not in a moral sense that in
the sense of Tony Stark was a was a dick
and then he became a good guy then he
went about going back to being a big
again wasn't anything like that
it was it was the rise and fall of Tony
Stark insofar as Tony Stark was a guy
who was selfish and only really cared
about himself and that was basically it
and then he under
you learned what it meant to become a
superhero and then became a good guy and
then went out in a blaze of glory that
was basically it you know it was it was
it's like the Jean Grey effect under
Chris Claremont right you know so
because of that when you look at the
character of Tony Stark he anchored us
to the MCU where like we were following
his story we were following the story of
Tony Stark in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe when you look at the character
of Captain America Captain America is is
intriguing because he was a man out of
time right you know he was a guy who was
virtually a nobody and then seemingly
overnight became probably the most
capable person on the planet Earth at
that point in time and then of course
you know went through his whole story
arc and then ultimately seemed to have
died but with with with these characters
with Iron Man and with Captain America
what makes them stand out is the fact
that they're relatable right that's what
makes them stand out is the fact that
they're tangible like we can we can feel
like we're part of them we could feel
like we're part of their story each one
of these guys has something interesting
to offer that that really sort of
expands that makes the MCU special for
Tony Stark a lot of us have been in
situations where we wanted to get out
right you know or we've improved on
ourselves as human beings and looking at
20 stark it's the story of any average
Joe out there right they start into this
world and they become a person they
become some version of themselves or
some period of time and maybe they
become disillusioned with them maybe
they decide they want to change their
ways it become something better but it's
basically the story of redemption this
idea that just because you're a person
now does not mean you're going to be
that kind of person for the rest of your
life that it's never too late to change
when you look at Captain America he's a
man out of time wait I mean which of us
have never been in a situation where we
felt out of place
right I mean Captain America's story is
kind of any extreme right he's literally
time-displaced wife Rosen and ice for 70
years and then thawed out in a world
that he doesn't even begin to recognize
but when you look at him like it's it's
sad and it's relatable right because
everything he knew and left it's gone
you know in the first Captain America
movie he lost Bucky Barnes you know and
then of course he's frozen and ice at
the end of at the end of that movie and
then he wakes up and he tries to find
some semblance of the life he knew only
to realize that Peggy Carter moved on
that she formed a family and and that
was basically it and now she's got
Alzheimer's she can remember him for 10
minutes at a time and then eventually
she dies you know there was no real
there was no real way for Captain
America to fit in you know the time
period he was living in was not
time and that was never his home and it
never would be his home and the indeed
he didn't actually find his home until
the end of Avengers in game when he went
back to the past and lived a full life
with Peggy Carter and so when you when
you look at those things it's like it's
it's touching and it's relatable in a
lot of ways because we've all felt out
of place we've all felt like we were
where we're not where we're supposed to
be or or something's missing out of our
lives or something along that and we
could read it take our our own
experiences and we could literally
project them on to Iron Man and on to
Captain America and then go forward from
there some people loved them so much for
the character of Thor he's intriguing
before wasn't really doing anything that
hadn't already been done Thor was
arrogant he was full of hubris and he
was punished for it by being banished to
the realm of Earth in order to learn
humility well I am an learned humility
when he was in a cave you know building
a suit with a box of scraps you know but
he was he was learning that that he
Millie so we'd already seen that we
don't need seen that Nance maybe there's
a little there's a little more fast pace
when I came to Thor but it was still the
same dance and so again you know each
one of these carrot is intriguing and
then you look at the care - respite oh
man and so when you when you look at the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as it stands
right now and really even any spider-man
film the question is what makes him fun
not like what makes what makes a
spider-man movie interesting well
spider-man learns about you know with
great power must come great
responsibility in all that kind of cool
stuff but what makes find a man movies
enjoyable other transitions flying it
like like swinging alongside spider-man
there's a reason why when you go and see
one of the movies with this character
that you don't have a locked-off shot
right which is to say a camera sitting
on a tripod and you got this big green
screen and all the camera shows as far
as the green screen cgi shows you it's
spider-man just swinging down you know a
building that's not how it works instead
spider-man jumps off a building and then
you swing you swoop down with him then
he swings back up and you shoots his
webbing and then he swoops down and
maybe you might do a backflip and then
get really low to the ground and back up
again that's what makes the spider-man
film so enjoyable it is following him
when he's web slinging and all that kind
of stuff in the MCU that wasn't a huge
part of it and then the interview is
more about the story of Peter Parker
about what it meant to become a
superhero but his story was
intrinsically tied into Iron Man right
like that's how people perceive it you
know Peter Parker was gonna be the next
Iron Men he was gonna be the replacement
for 20 Stark and in fact that's
literally what it was so when you start
left in the glasses said you're my new
you're my heir
and so because of the fact that that
that Peter Parker was really the last
remaining character in the end in the
MCU that we could identify with it
didn't really leave anybody else after
he left right I mean what's the story of
Sam Wilson Falcon like you don't know
about his parents you don't know his
backstory you know he was in the
military and that's it that's really the
only thing you really know that Falcon
is what you learned along the way when
he was a sidekick of Captain America
what's the story of Bucky Barnes story
of Bucky Barnes he was a childhood
friend of Steve Rogers okay now you
don't know what his upbringing was like
you didn't see the flashbacks to when he
was a little kid and being raised by his
parents when he first met Steve Rogers
like you didn't really get a hold on
that I mean you did to a degree but but
only insofar as it related to Steve
Rogers who is a story of Steve Rogers
being told and Bucky Barnes was just
kind of along for the ride you know and
and so because of that you look at the
character of Black Widow and you look at
the character of Hawkeye Hawkeye was
interesting because of the fact that
that he's a guy with a family that we
didn't know about and then eventually we
discovered it and it really wasn't until
he became Ronin that he really became
interesting and that was for a very very
short amount of time for a Black Widow
we're gonna get her backstory in a movie
but you know up until the point where we
see her backstory she's just a character
who's there who's a really good spy
there really isn't a whole lot going for
the characters in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe outside of the ones that are
considered to be you know Top Billing
ray I am Man Captain America in spite of
it make sense because the Iron Man built
the MCU Captain America it's Captain
America and spider-man is a face of
Marvel so it makes sense in that regard
the question is if you yanked spider-man
out of that what kind of effect will it
have on the MCU I mean Marvel is making
movies about the Eternals I was making
movies about Shane team I was making
movies about about about blade and while
that's cool what people need and what
people wanted when it came to the next
phase of the MCU is something to carry
them over people didn't want to go see
the new phase of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and feel like it's totally
disconnected from everything that
happened before it and removing Captain
America removing Ironman from the
landscape leaves only spider-man and if
you cut him out there's no connection
there's nothing that makes me feel like
what I'm seeing as part of the last 10
years it makes you just feel like last
10 years might as well not have happened
and now we just have what's going on
next now a lot of that really kind of
remains to be seen in terms of how the
movies are played out and how they're
done but if they're anything like the
origin stories of years gone by then
they're going to be isolated they're
going to be kept in Kevin
kind of a closed-off closed-off
confinement now could find space and
that's basically it there might be a few
references to what happened before but
it won't feel cohesive won't feel tied
into everything else I mean think about
the four movie the the Thor was a 4-1
think about that you know that was a
movie that was kept solo in in isolation
think about the ant-man film Scott Lang
think about I think about I don't know
like like I am an one or two or three
think about like Captain America one
like for the most part all the solo
films all the films that were designed
to focus on a particular character did
just that and didn't really incorporate
a ton of elements to the rest of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that made it
feel cohesive what made it feel cohesive
were the Easter eggs Captain America's
shield showing up in the Ironman and
then one of the Iron Man movies really
in the first and second high man film
Thor's hammer falling in New Mexico like
Tony Stark going to visit Thunderbolt
Ross at the end of the incredible whole
film and saying I'm forming a team and
Nick Fury showing up at the end of Iron
Man one of the post-credits scenes
saying I'm forming the Avengers that's
what made the film's cohesive guardians
of the galaxy the exact same way and so
because of that having no no feeling of
cohesiveness would ultimately make the
MCU like it won't fit would totally
destroy it but I don't know if it would
really make it to the next five to ten
years the way that Marvel hopes if it
did it would limp along because blades
an interesting character sure but
blatant Marvel Comics was always out
there in no man's land
he was always isolated from pretty much
everything else he'd cross over a few
times sure but Blake was a care to the
dealt with vampires no monsters
different things like that he didn't
really see blade team-up with the
Avengers all that often it was just kind
of his stories out there by himself
doing his own thing and a lot of the
solo stories are like that it's only
really it's it's it's intriguing in that
way and so because of that you're
talking about removing a character from
from the landscape of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that's the only real
connection fans have for the last 10
years and then saying everybody get
ready for the next five to ten years and
this is kind of like but why though
because you feel like a part of yourself
is missing you know because we were a
part of that journey we were there a lot
of people in blue not a lot of folks
grew up with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe they were really really young
when they saw Iron Man one
and there you know however all they are
now you know they're 13 or they're
they're 17 or they're 20 or something
like that you know with with having seen
the last 10 years of the moment
Cinematic Universe they grew up with it
it encompassed their preteen their
teenage and their young adult years and
so to remove that connection what
ultimately I think stifle and possibly
even kill the MCU especially if the
blade movies the shang-chi film the
eternal film but if those are not well
received if those are this kind of like
you know and people aren't really
feeling them which is entirely possible
you know one of the things heat mind
about the MCU while they have done some
great movies out there doesn't mean that
they're incapable of failing it doesn't
mean they're incapable of making a bad
film look at for three or four - though
a 33 I thought was pretty it was pretty
enjoyable if you enjoyed comedy Thor - I
think we can all just kind of agree with
just not good you know and then just
kind of go from there but nonetheless I
think smile and stay in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe keeps the Marvel
Cinematic Universe alive I think it
keeps it afloat I think it helps to
carry the fan base the viewings the
movie-going audience from the furred
from the the last 10 years over into you
the next 10 years know next 15 years or
how many years that we have and that's
really gonna what the that's what
they're gonna need they're gonna need to
have a series of film but you need to
have a connecting film you know some
kind of film that brings that that sort
of bridges the gap between the previous
you know eras you know the infinity saga
basically between one saga to the next
but keeps people attached keeps people
going and keeps people believing that
it's all part of one great big huge
giant cohesive story which really kind
of begs the question is there one great
big huge story arc here or is it really
just a series of disconnected sagas and
if that's the case does that bode well
like is that something that people are
interested in seeing I guess only time
will tell but nonetheless that's kind of
my stance here is that that spider-man's
staying in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
keeps it alive it keeps it afloat it
gives it a better chance of succeeding
in the interim between the time that it
ended or at least at the time that
Avengers in game ended and when the
x-men of the Fantastic Four show up
because at the end of the day I think we
can all really kind of agree that while
we are going to see some cool stuff I am
interested in seeing dr. strange to you
know going into the multiverse with with
with Scarlet Witch while I am interested
in seen blade and scene shang-chi and
the Eternals fellow I'm looking forward
all that stuff in the Disney Plus shows
I'm looking forward to seeing all those
things at the end of the day they're
really just kind of hold over
they're just pulling me over until the
x-men and the Fantastic Four hit him
that's really what it is and I think for
most people it's that way like hey that
stuff's cool though but like like
Wolverine though like I really want to
see well very like I want to see
Deadpool I don't want to see all that
stuff you know we're just kind of
waiting for those waiting for those
films to come in which is really what
we're looking forward to the most but
without being said guys let me know down
in the comments section let me know what
you guys think you know how do you guys
feel no you guys see this but anyway
without that you said we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explained to make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later hey here's a
question is is doing that really like a
rude gesture overseas I don't know I
always did it because it was a piece on
I guess people say to do that instead
but that feels stupid makes me feel like
a hippie so anyway nothing he said I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]